am tatort jetzt unser kollege michael
engelberg michael gibt es mittlerweile
neuigkeiten vor allem was die frage der
täter angeht ja gut morgennebel hier aus
amsterdam
hier ist es heute wesentlich ruhiger als
gestern die leute habe ich den eindruck
sind gegenüber gestern noch mehr
betroffenen ja es gibt tatsächlich
neuigkeiten
die polizei hat nicht viel verlautbart
allerdings die journalisten kollegen
sind wirklich mit eifer dabei
ich glaube dass sie alle recherchieren
um die informationen weiterzuleiten um
auch peter de vries zu zeigen dass sie
mit ihm sind es gibt neuigkeiten und
zwar gestern wurde schon verlautbart
dass es zwei festnahmen gab einen
dritten tatverdächtigen anfangs hat man
wieder freigelassen bei dem einen
tatverdächtigen soll es sich um einen
polnischen mann handeln kamel
er soll tatsächlich auch gerade aktuell
in seinem heimatland polen gesucht
werden dort wegen raubdelikten und
diebstahls er soll bei dieser tat den
fluchtwagen gefahren haben der
tatsächlich dann auch auf der autobahn
gestoppt wurde und er und sein
mutmaßlicher komplize den og er soll die
tödlichen schüsse abgegeben haben er ist
21 und wie wir erfahren haben rapper
sein aus rotterdam
jetzt will die polizei tatsächlich auch
keine weiteren informationen weitergeben
es wird nicht mal berichtet wer sie
vertritt vor gericht nur eines ist
bekannt dass morgen tatsächlich die haft
vorführung passieren soll jetzt gehen
wir mal einmal so ein bisschen auf
diesen tatort da kann man mal sehen wie
sich dieser tatort auch ein bisschen
verändert hat auf der linken seite kann
man sehen welche bedeutung peter de
vries hatte helden sterben nicht helden
werden nicht sterben auf der linken
seite haben kinder spielzeug abgelegt
auf der rechten seite sieht man kannte
wollen das sind rosinenbrötchen dass es
eine niederländische spezialität die
muss ein enger vertrauter von peter de
vries hinterlassen haben weil peter de
vries tatsächlich an langen prozesstagen
immer die
bekannte bäumen gegessen hat um sich zu
stärken es sind sehr viele weitere
blumen hinzugekommen hier sehen wir noch
ein herz lieber peter kommt zurück
du bist unser held und ein großes liebe
herz also man sieht die bevölkerung hier
in amsterdam in den niederlanden steht
weiterhin an der seite von peter r de
vries und seiner familie weil es um
seinen gesundheitszustand weiterhin
keine neuigkeiten gibt
michael man weiß ja jetzt mittlerweile
auch das de vries auch viele feinde so
muss man es sagen hatte durch seinen job
durch seine investigative arbeit kannst
du uns da etwas mehr zu sagen wer also
alles jetzt tatsächlich ihm schlechtes
wenn ich vielleicht sogar den tod
gewünscht hat also peter er de vries ist
seit über 40 jahren in diesem geschäft
er war der erste der eine investigativ
sendung hatte er hat ganz ganz viele
fälle nicht nur in den niederlanden
sondern weltweit aufgedeckt und
natürlich und das wissen der reporter
natürlich alle die versuchen sachen
aufzudecken
nicht jeder ist freund davon peter r de
vries ist momentan berater in einem der
größten prozesse in den niederlanden da
geht es um ganz ganz viele morgen im
drogen mafia milieu tat ist er berater
des jahr des kronzeugen und der erste
anwalt dieses grund zeugen ist schon
erschossen worden und auch der bruder
von abb also man sieht man wird hier in
alle richtungen ermitteln
der fremdkörper aus der justizminister
hat gestern abend bei seinem
zusammentreffen mit der niederländischen
mit der amsterdamer bürgermeisterin und
dem chef von rtl 4 boulevard noch mal
gesagt man möge jetzt bitte nicht
spekulieren
die polizei würde hier wirklich alles
tun um das aufzuklären und allein daran
sieht man das natürlich auch auf der
justiz auf der polizei auf der inneren
sicherheit hier enormer druck herrscht
weil die fragen natürlich aufkommen wie
weit können wir unsere bevölkerung
schützen und wie weit können wir auch
journalisten schützen
vielen herzlichen dank michael engelberg
für uns am tatort in amsterdam
dankeschön
wir sind bild und wir liefern dir deine
news auf youtube zum nächsten video
kommst du hier
und vergiss bitte nicht unseren kanal
abonnieren